[Applaudissements]
pour être franc je suis un peu embêté
parce que je devais aller chercher mon
fils à la crèche aujourd'hui alors mon
fils il a deux ans et demi ça un petit
blond avec des grands yeux bleus
il s'appelle base il est franchement
mais il est trop mignon
et donc je devais aller chercher à la
crèche
sauf que je me suis retrouvé coincé dans
une réunion mais interminable vous voyez
le genre
donc j'en vois un texto à ma femme pour
lui demander si elle peut aller chercher
basile à ma place et là elle me renvoie
une réponse avec des émaux dit mais
c'est pas si vous voyez le type de
réponse les emoji vous comprenez rien à
ce qu'elle est il maudit
donc c'est à dire que moi quand je vois
ça je me dis alors soit elle est en
train de me dire non mais henri tu te
fous de moi là mais ce soir c'est même
pas la peine de rentrer à la maison
c'est mort ou bien elle est en train de
me dire ah non non non mais henry la
voix c'est pas possible moi aussi je
suis bloqué je peux pas y aller chez
désolé vous dire que c'est pas facile
d'interpréter des est maudit quand on
n'est pas traducteur des maudits mais
parce que je sais pas si vous savez
traducteur des moggi aujourd'hui c'est
un job il ya crise brownie qu'est le
premier traducteur des wadji
professionnels ça fait partie tous ces
nouveaux jobs au même titre que data
säntis scrum master ou designers dans
tous les cas il va falloir vous y
habituer parce que des nouveaux jobs on
va en voir passer tenez par exemple
parce que on est tous concernés 1
si je prends trois personnes dans la
salle l'a par exemple vos trois en face
parmi vous trois il y en a deux qui vont
connaître d'énormes changements dans
leur job qu'est ce que ça nous disent eh
ben ça nous dit qu'on est ignorant face
à la compétence de demain et cette
ignorance
à mon sens c'est une chance
c'est une chance de se réinventer c'est
une chance d'évoluer
c'est une chance de réussir
en tout cas moi c'est ce qui m'arrive si
on revient une dizaine d'années en
arrière
j'ai 25 ans je suis diplômée d'un master
de gestion il faut se lancer dans la vie
active
alors dans ma promo ya thibault il
enfile son costard et va bosser chez
kpmg en audit et puis à sarah avec ses
longs talons et son petit ailleurs elle
va bosser en marketing chez l'oréal
parce qu'elle le vaut bien
et moi qu'est ce que je décide de faire
et ben moi je décide de me lancer dans
une carrière artistique
je deviens musiciens donc je fais le
tour de france en chantant mes chansons
avec ma guitare
pourtant je peux vous dire que j'étais
pas prédestiné à être musicien
premièrement j'ai pas une formation à
proprement parler en tant que musicien
j'ai appris en autodidacte
en plus je viens pas du tout d'un milieu
artistique
ma mère elle est philosophe mon père et
businessman donc autant vous dire que je
connaissais pas grand chose alors
pourquoi je vous raconte ça c'est parce
que justement ce qui a été un élément
vraiment important et ce que je retiens
de cette expérience
ça a été de se lancer donc je vous
invite à oser et l'ignorance lancer ou
donc au bout de cinq ans je décide de
garder les projet musical en parallèle
d'un job plus classique et mon projet
musical je me mets à collaborer avec
assène jacques balle un énorme musicien
qui à 25 ans de métier de plus que moi
et qui devient mon mentor il passe une
chose assez étrange dès ma première
session avec hassen j'ai l'impression
que je suis un gamin qui a jamais fait
une musique de scène alors que pourtant
ça fait quand même cinq ans que je
faisais ce métier j'ai fait des
centaines de concerts j'ai sorti de
disque et là je me retrouve au bout
d'une heure avec hassen en ayant
l'impression que c'est la première fois
que je fais de la musique et que j'ai
tout à apprendre
il faut dire que ça vous apprend
l'humilité et ce qui est encore plus
intéressant c'est que depuis je
travaillais cassen ça fait plusieurs
années
à chaque session j'ai ce même sentiment
de
voilà d'être le gamin qui est en train
de tout découvrir
et finalement je vais même chercher ce
sentiment j'ai cherché en fait mais zone
de d'un confort mais zone d'ignorance
pour pouvoir évoluer
c'est ça qui me fait progresser donc
finalement c'est cultiver mon ignorance
et donc moi je sais pas où vous en êtes
aujourd'hui
mais justement si vous êtes dans votre
job depuis plusieurs années où vous êtes
un un étudiant sur la même matière
depuis plusieurs années je vous invite
vous aussi à cultiver votre ignorance à
sortir de votre zone de confort pour
pouvoir évoluer pour pouvoir progresser
et ça vous pourrez faire si vous êtes
prêts à réagir à votre ignorance et
d'ailleurs ça se voit pas mal dans la
suite de mon parcours c'est à dire le
job que j'ai en parallèle de mon projet
musical à savoir que j'ai suivi un cours
en ligne accessible à tous
un mook d'un prof de musique que je
suivais depuis un moment j'ai trouvé
l'expérience pédagogique est tellement
énorme du mook que je suis allé frapper
à la porte d'un des acteurs majeurs de
la formation en ligne à savoir open 4
août et ils m'ont embauché dans l'eure
dans leurs équipes commerciales et je me
souviens que mon manager il m'a dit à
l'époque
il m'a dit écoute sur ton cv j'embauche
pas sur ton cv parce qu'en fait sur ton
cv n'a pas les compétences de commercial
par contre c'est ton parcours qui
m'intéresse je pense que tu peux avoir
ce maïs est d'aller chercher les bons
éléments pour pouvoir être un bon
commercial
maintenant c'est à tous de me prouver
que j'ai raison et c'est ce que j'ai
fait donc puisque j'avais un mentor dans
ma qu'artistique
je vais chercher un mentor dans mon job
de commercial et je suis allé demander
au culot à nicolas mirail qui est le
directeur commercial de linkedin france
de menthe aurait il a été d'accord et
résultat on se voit une heure par mois
et on fait le point et il donne toutes
les clés pour pouvoir mieux piloter mon
activité commerciale et je me suis fait
un bon ami au passage ensuite
j'entendais parler du sochaux céline
comme nouvelles compétences pour les
commerciaux à l'heure du numérique
donc j'ai suivi des conférences en ligne
sur le sol céline et j'ai aussi à me
créer une petite expertise sur le sujet
au point que maintenant ça m'arrive de
faire des conférences sur un sochaux
sellings à mon tour l'idée c'était
vraiment d'aller chercher les
compétences selon les besoins qu'ils
aient émergé au quotidien dernièrement
par exemple j'accompagne énormément mes
clients sur des gros projets
stratégiques qui dit projet dit gestion
de projet donc j'ai suivi un cours en
ligne un book sur la gestion de projet
et je peux vous dire que je m'en sers
tous les jours et donc qu'en faisant ça
je me suis retrouvé à être aussi
performants voire plus performant que
des commerciaux qui pouvait avoir 10 ans
d'expérience de plus que moi mais qui
avait pas remis à jour leurs compétences
et si on prend un peu de recul
finalement d'aller piocher à droite à
gauche des compétences par itérations
successives en fonction des feedbacks et
des besoins que je pouvais identifié sur
mon quotidien dans mon job et va en fait
sans le savoir
j'étais en train d'appliquer les règles
de l'agilité les grands principes de
l'agilité à mon parcours j'étais en
train de devenir un apprenant à j et ça
ça c'est une compétence essentielle dans
un monde qui bouge comme le nôtre il
faut devenir cette apprenant agi parce
que vos hearts qu'ils vos compétences
techniques elles sont vouées à être
obsolète hyper rapidement alors
j'imagine que quand je dis ça il y en a
parmi vous qui commence à paniquer je
pense aux trois tout à l'heure qui
depuis est alors commencer un petit peu
a paniqué et ben en fait il n'y a pas
lieu de paniquer c'est dire que même si
vous vous dites mais attend en ruine en
train de m'expliquer que mes compétences
elles vont être obsolète que j'ignore la
compétence de demain dans mon job
mais comment je fais pour east
employables mois
devenez justement cette apprenant à jean
qu'on va regarder aujourd'hui c'est
votre capacité à apprendre votre
capacité à vous adapter à un monde qui
change
et pour ça commençait par oser
l'ignorance accepté l'incertitude
ensuite fait de cette ignorance votre
allié cultiver la et réagissez à cette
ignorance en formant au quotidien par
exemple vous pourriez très bien je sais
pas si parmi vous il y en a qui tiennent
un journal intime mais vous pourriez
très bien commencé par tenir un journal
d'apprentissage dans lequel tous les
jours vous allez écrire ce que vous avez
appris dans la journée et ce qui serait
intéressant d'apprendre demain ça va
changer votre vie et vous allez
commencer à rentrer dans ce match 7 de
l'apprenant agit bon c'est pas tout mais
il faut que j'appelle ma femme pour
savoir si elle allait chercher vas-y
parce que sinon moi je vais retrouver
les services sociaux à ma porte ce soir
donc je vous invite à devenir c'est
apprenant agi parce que la compétence
absolue dans un monde qui évolue c'est
de savoir cultiver la prochaine merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]